hey guys Pete here gonna do a Game of
Thrones video today because I have a
book giveaway that was completed and I
need to give away my book so this is
going to be a non spoiler version of
everything we know video about Game of
Thrones Season seven that means that I'm
going to go with all the promotional
material we have and stuff we've seen
but avoid any spoilers as to a lot of
the stuff that we've been talking about
in the off season main reason being that
I want everyone to be able to watch this
and the book giveaway was announced on
those spoilers and non spoilers video
and some people are just avoiding the
hardcore splits so the game of Thrones
Season 7 release date is drawing near if
you missed a giant block of ice melting
event on Facebook live the data
announced with Sunday July 16th at 9
p.m. Eastern Time Eastern Standard Time
which is the normal airing time that it
always has been on the east coast of the
United States the premiere is 59 minutes
long and I'm guessing that much of what
we've seen in these release photos that
have come out one's from HBO
particularly the shots of Queen Daenerys
Targaryen on Westerosi soil and Jon Snow
the king in the north shots from
Winterfell most of those are going to be
in that first episode as far as we can
tell and we'll talk more about those
photos later if the 59 minute running
time I mentioned about the first episode
sounds long it sorta is overall the
seasons the average length of an episode
is about 55 minutes which means episode
1 is almost 10 percent longer than usual
in season 7 there is only one episode
that's less than 59 minutes and that's
episode 4 so overall the episodes are
longer with the last two being super
long here's the x rundown and don't
forget this is the shorter season with
only 7 episodes episode 1 is 59 minutes
episode 2 59 minutes episode 3 is 63
minutes episode 4 is 50 minutes it's the
little guy
episode 5 59 episode 671 low and episode
7 is a whopping
81 minutes which is by far the longest
Game of Thrones episode of an actually
Episode six would have been the longest
episode of all time as well since it is
the longest episode record or whatever
it was set by the season 6 finale the
winds of winter which was 68 minutes so
the longest episode you've ever seen is
three minutes shorter than episode 6 and
13 minutes shorter than the season
finale you're trying to do the math in
your head these longer episodes are
equal to 8 normal episodes so you know
we only have 7 but it's really like a
usually we would have 10 I made a video
about this a few months ago in the
comments were split about more shorter
episodes versus fewer longer episodes
but this is what bums me out when I
think about it 7 episodes as beefy as
they are means that we start in mid-july
on the 16th but end off by the last
Sunday in August supposing they show
them on consecutive Sundays which we
don't know for sure
since HBO hasn't released its August
schedule yet but if that's the case that
SuperDuper long season finale will air
on August 27th couple this with the fact
that HBO has said that season 8 probably
be delayed and actually won't air until
2019 due to the production time that
goes into it so it's just a lot of not
being in season or whatever you want to
call it not to mention that we'll be
waiting for the shortest run of episodes
yet with the confirmation that they gave
us that season 8 will actually only be 6
episodes how long those would be we
don't know but still I mean we just
don't have a lot of time left in this
and it's going to take a while to get
there so it's just a little bit
depressing for me it is what it is
though so let's look at what else we've
got as far as promotional material and
then I'll announce the winner of the
book gift since I've already made an
extended break down of the full-length
trailer which you can go watch in any
time it actually has the trailer in it
in full at the beginning I'll just do
some quick highlights here of what we
saw in that trailer we start out with a
speech from Queen Cersei talking about
all
enemies and we see her kick-ass new
mapper which was probably one of the
biggest surprises for me we see here on
the throne with Jamie by her side with
the Valyrian steel blade widow's wail on
his hip
that's the blade that was forged for
Joffrey back at his wedding and you know
was made from Ned broadsword ice while
they're in there we see that she's being
presented with someone which based on
just the cues that we've seen from her
speech and who might be there to be on
her side it's probably you're on Greyjoy
there's no confirmation of that but
that's just my guest person we also see
that Daenerys will finally make it to
Westeros and specifically the ancestral
Targaryen home Dragonstone we see the
Tyrians there with her and get a light
like a glimpse of drogon and her new
throne room inside of the castle but she
boasted with rocky and the unsullied in
action the former at Casterly Rock which
is cool for a lot of reasons we see Jon
Snow in the Hall at Winterfell with
Davos and salsa at his side there are
other northern houses in attendance
including the fan-favorite Lyanna
Mormont and of course Littlefinger is
not far away
because Sansa there you can imagine this
gathering has something to do with the
white Walker problem that's coming from
the north since it's all northern houses
and John is the one who is most aware of
how big of a threat this is little
finger is weaseling around and that's
not surprising we see Theon looking
scared in a fiery battle at sea which is
very cool Arya is looking pretty good
and she's making her way north is at
least that's what it looks like here we
get an action shot of tormund and Jon
running north of the wall most likely
and also a romantic scene between grey
worm and Masson Dee the trailer finishes
off with the Dothraki riding with Drogo
and above and Jon Snow leaves us with
the words the Great War is here so yeah
it's a lot of stuff it's really cool new
footage is always awesome check out the
trailer breakdown for sure you know
you can get more into what's going on
there besides that trailer we've gotten
piles of pictures and a poster slash
animation of the night King I made a
video about this too but the main
takeaway is that the head honcho and his
White Walkers are coming in the
animation you can see Jon Snow's image
in his eye so check out the video for
that they're supposed to be Cersei in
the Narus in May or two but um jury's
out on whether that's the case or not
other pictures we've seen include a lot
of Jon Snow who appears to be moving
around based on the outfits that he
wears they sort of have various levels
of snow protection or protection from
the cold
lots of shots have been airs on the
shore below Dragonstone in one truly
insane photo showcasing just how big
dragon has ah so there's some other
stuff we're going to get into but let's
go ahead and talk about this book
giveaway really quick
I had a giveaway for subscribers and if
you left a comment you entered in here I
went through and ran the random comment
picker picked out one commenter from
each video and then put all those names
in the virtual hat and the winner turned
out to be Carl the first the Carl if
you're watching this I would be glad to
send you the 20th anniversary hardcover
edition of Game of Thrones by George RR
martin send me a message through the
email on my page and i will hook it up
after the regular full length trailer we
got a couple of other features or I
don't know maybe you'd call them feature
X about the different things that go
into making Game of Thrones the first
one was called a story in cloth which is
cool I would say go check that out on
the HBO YouTube account if you haven't
seen it yet because it's definitely
worth watching a lot of sketches and
talking about how they build up all
these crazy costumes and stoller them
and everything it's pretty neat there
were a couple revelations that may have
come out of this one was we see a shot
of Santa and it looks like the person
behind her is got needle on their hip so
that would be an indication that those
two are together are
Sansa I don't want to speculate anymore
before you on that since it's a non
spoiler video but then we also saw some
gear that was for a giant we see a giant
drawing and things and some people are
speculating that that might be white
giant like one of the Giants that's been
killed and come back but it's basically
speculation either way it's very cool
you see all the different characters
kind of scenes and definitely worth
watch the next feature that we got was
about location filming and we hear from
the cast members about going to these
different places particularly Iceland
and Spain it's a cool feature as well we
also got one on special effects where we
see how they make some of that really
cool stuff there's actual parts that we
see from the trail or the upcoming stuff
most of us from season 6 but that's
definitely worth a look too and speaking
of special effects we learned that Game
of Thrones will be setting a record for
the most people set on fire so basically
they are you know there's dragons
involved in the show that have gotten
big and people are catching on fire
apparently Game of Thrones catches 73
people on fire in one sequence and
actually caught 20 people in one shot on
fire at the same time so that's like you
know way more than anybody's done before
I think they said something in the
article about 18 and Braveheart
partially on fire and something like 13
and for Saving Private Ryan so this is a
massive fiery scale that is not ever
been seen anywhere after all that we got
some more photos from the north around
Winterfell and we got this the coolest
one out of that was a picture of Lord
beric Dondarrion who if you remember in
season six had mentioned heading north
and he had to hound with him at the time
so we see that he's in the snow and he's
definitely involved in something up
there so that's good to see
Davos more tour mummy got a lot of
photos of torment and Arya and different
situations and I'm all that's
interesting to check out the day after
that we got one more big batch and here
we have Davos and Jon Snow leaving when
FL is what it looks like we get a lot of
fan favorites here like Bella Ramsey as
Lyanna Mormont Podrick little Podrick
Payne lots of pictures of Sam and Gilly
which are always cool now that Sam is at
the Citadel and one of brand who looks
like he might be having a vision while
he's sitting in the snow so that's about
it that we have right now like I said
I'm going to make a spoilery version of
this in some way for all the other
stuffs that we've seen and then watching
but you know that's all I'm going to go
into here let me know what you're
interested in seeing on the lead-up to
the thing once the season actually
starts I'll definitely be doing episode
recap and reviews and bonus videos based
on what we see probably some Q&A if we
got some time for that I'm sort of neck
deep in Twin Peaks right now because it
is the most it's probably the most fun
show to speculate on of all time and
it's in full swing and it's actually
going to go through and be still on
after Game of Thrones starts and
finishes so that's taking up quite a bit
of time but I'm definitely in Game of
Thrones mode right now leading up I'm
watching my rewatch --is and looking for
different things that might be of
interest my main thought is maybe doing
a character series on where everybody
was at the end of season 6 but let me
know what your thoughts are and what you
want to see and I will talk to you soon
congratulations again to the winner of
the book giveaway make sure you get in
touch with me and please like this video
and subscribe thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon